[Musique]
dans le cadre du Plan un million
d'arbres lancés par le Département de
classe de l'école du petit tampon se
sont rendus au domaine Archambault ce
jeudi 29 juin pour une plantation avec
la splden pour l'ouverture de la
séquence participé à une animation
futurelle où on a un compteur qui
raconte une histoire sur l'environnement
la nature et ensuite on va aller sur le
site avec ses enfants pour planter des
arbres
endémie et indigènes et chacun donc va
être accompagné des agents de la SPA
Eden on va lui expliquer
quel arbre il y a dans les mains comment
il faut planter et donc comment
entretenir cette biodiversité sur le
site archango gardien de la conservation
et de la restauration du site envahi par
les espèces exotiques et envahissantes
l'asbl s'occupe de la production en
pépinières sur le site de la récolte et
de la plantation
travail qui nous reste à faire et que
nous faisons depuis plusieurs années
maintenant c'est de récolter enfin
d'abord d'identifier et de cartographier
toutes les espèces qui sont présentes
sur sur le site les espèces indigènes et
endémiques il y en a plus de 80 qui sont
remarquables sur ce site là et ensuite
une fois que nous avons fait les
récoltes de diasports sous forme de
bouture de graines de de de plantule
également et donc nous ramenons ces
diasports là en production en pépinière
la peau de la production se fait sur
place sur le site et ensuite une fois
que les différentes étapes ont été
parcourues c'est-à-dire on part de la
germination on passe par l'élevage on
termine par l'adaptation et le sevrage
une fois que les plantes sont sevrées
elles sont remises en plantation remise
en terre sur le site même par nos
équipes dédiées qui travaillent sur le
site du 1er janvier 31 décembre
le but de cette opération transmettre
toute la connaissance sur le patrimoine
naturel de ce site aux enfants du coin
afin qu'ils deviennent eux aussi acteurs
de la conservation de ce patrimoine
l'éclosion
de
Levan l'élevage et 3 le l'adaptation
et qu'il y a beaucoup d'étapes pour que
les poissons
là faut prendre la plante pour la plante
faut se dire deux doigts à la racine
retourner la plante on tape un petit peu
dessus et enlever le sachet ensuite ben
mettre dedans et pousser la terre et
bien mettre la terre de souffle bien
tapisser je crois oui
la split dance
mille pieds de bois avant la fin de
l'année dans le cadre du Plan un million
d'arbres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]